I love this headline from Fox News
Jeffrey Epstein documents name A-list
celebrities I hate this a little
clickbait news bricking news just a
little bit just a little bit because it
is factually true and it's relatively
vague but I got to be honest I don't
know how you would actually title this
story while trying to provide the
context that they're not potentially
wrongdoers TMZ just listed like the name
like names and then just said no
wrongdoing it just listed in the in the
headline that there was no wrongdoing
found and then then the Crone underneath
it was like they had no R doing it's
just all no they put it right in the
headline like right in the main headline
on the website it listed it almost like
a lot of people would say depending on
what your opinion on the media is like
oh they're just covering up for them
because my favorite thing to always
point out is like whenever they talk
about Epstein like there's like several
documentaries on Epstein that are all on
like Hulu and all these things and they
all have pictures of him and Trump on
there because the media hates Trump and
they want to talk TMZ is like these
people are bread and butter you cannot
disperse their good name we need them to
create our beautiful content I mean the
fox story is is I agree with Tim it can
be really hard to headline because like
you're trying to get it out quickly you
you know a long headline is is wordy on
the other hand it was annoying screwing
screw SC oh my gosh scrolling through
this article because they'd be like ah
yes somebody asked if you would ever met
George Lucas from Star Wars and she was
like No And so that's the mention or
something exactly exactly I'm just
shocked about this whole thing is that
there's no Bank Executives named but so
like Wall Street is like clean from all
this so it's only like you know no I
mean this is just who they asked about
in the deposition saying there's not one
single this is this is these are not the
Epstein client fils no no I know that
but I'm just saying like I mean they
obviously would be part of it well known
like Wall Street Executives that's I
would say these documents don't get
anywhere near the majority of the
clients that we want to see exposed
because this is this was part of a
defamation lawsuit a lot of these
documents that are being released are
related to the original investigation
into Epstein that were used as evidence
in the defamation trial that's my
understanding could be wrong I that's
what's being reported we be very very
very careful here because you got a lot
of people whose names are getting
wrapped up in for that deposition was
Paul Beach who did the investigation
right uh I don't know was it yeah that's
I remember like Paul Beach did like this
thorough investigation and then that's
what only it didn't lead to any state or
federal charges only led to that civil
that's why was like there's so many
missing pieces to everything going on in
this I love how that okay so let's go
through the list they say Naomi Campbell
is named leard DiCaprio Kate at Bruce
Willison Cameron Diaz George Lucas
Michael Jackson Kevin spy okay now that
last one all right now the last one okay
other know watch did you watch his thing
with Tucker Oh yeah I don't know what's
going on
man the Kevin SP he ruined House of
Cards it was so good and then the last
season just sucked technically like he
didn't ruin the show what bad his bad
life choices are what are what ruined
the show show was so good he's got to
win an award for when he was accused of
all this wrongdoing he should win an
award for his response where they're
just like Kevin spy you've been accused
of rape on several instances and he goes
I'm gay I am a gay man I'm choosing to
live my life this way I thought that was
incredible but also he doesn't um he's
not interested in the the flavor that
Epstein seems to be offering right so I
I don't know that this is actually he he
is not a good person necessarily but I
don't know that he's actually uh someone
we'd expect to see on the list at all
there are a lot of people who are
accusing him that have mysteriously died
in the last several years four or five
have uh passed away before you know
being able to take him to court but he
was acquitted what now twice in in the
UK and and more but that video with with
Tucker Carlson I was like we were
watching we're like who is this for like
I legitimately can't figure out who it's
for it it almost looks fake like if you
watch the video full screen on a larger
TV it almost doesn't look real and it
feels like this weird like like he he it
almost looks green screen in a way like
he green screen tu or yeah like they
added him in there and he do and like he
makes these great Illusions to House of
Cards in the show when he talks about
you know pushing journalists in a
certain direction which is a very clear
push to the end of season one it was
just it was it was rough but it was it
was really weird to watch cuz I'm like
who is he Tucker Carlson's wearing like
acid washed jeans I'm like is this
trying to say this is an AI generator
video I don't think it is but like there
was just if it was surely Tucker's team
would have spoken out yeah yeah like
he's wearing acid wash jeans in there
though maybe he's just like trying to
explore his sense of fashion though but
but no cuz in the thing like Kevin
Spacey like basically alludes to he's
like I he's like do you ever watch
Netflix anymore he says that space goes
probably as much as you watch Fox these
days I do want to say uh I am fascinated
that of all the names that are in there
Jimmy Kimmel is not and but the reason
is not because I think you know I want
outright I'm not accusing Jim Jimmy Kim
doing anything wrong it's that he was
actually business partners with
Epstein's chef and so when Aaron Rogers
said you know Jimmy Kimmel must be
worried about this and then Jimmy Kimmel
threatened to sue him I was like well
hold on yeah like what do you have to
hide it's not the that it's that what
Roger said was completely reasonable
this this guy worked with what was the
guy Chef Perry Lang or whatever the
guy's name was he was Epstein's personal
chef and my understanding there's a
report that said that they were uh
co-owners of a restaurant or that Jimmy
Kimmel was in some way involved there's
videos of them they're friends so if
Jimmy Kimmel appeared in this document I
would not be surprised I'm not I'm not
saying he did anything wrong all these
celebrities that are being named uh 99%
of there's no accusation of of
wrongdoing they just ask them did you
ever see Bruce Willis there no well and
anyone who's named I'm sure does not
actually want their name to come up in
this even if it's completely inoc it
would be nicer to not be involved at all
just look at his reaction like he was
like if you keep mentioning my now I'm
going to sue it was just like why you're
like getting so like jumpy about this
the average P but the thing is though is
we're we're pointing out the fact that
when you read these documents a lot of
these people aren't accused of
wrongdoing just putting your name and
Epstein's name next to each other now is
enough to tarnish you so it doesn't
matter if they're not being accused of
wrongdoing just by being associated with
the going to cover you up they have
trouble but so you feel like Kimmel's
like sphar was somewhat reasonable I
yeah I I think if if you're not doing
anything wrong and your name comes up in
something like this then it's probably a
pretty reasonable response to be like I
don't want to be attached to this at all
and there's no legal recourse right yeah
it's not like you can sue the documents
for life like there's kind of nothing
you can do about it you feel like it's
like there's a lot of like ghoulishness
to all of this like people were talking
about how all of these names coming out
has been like album drops for like it's
been made light of so much that it's
kind of hard to when you you have to re
you have to read what's actually
happening here to reacquaint yourself
with just how horrific so much of this
stuff is and if if we were to get a
Client List in some ways would people be
like but we already kind of got this
weird list that sort of meant nothing is
in some ways this this weird drip of
information actually making people less
interested in what was going on in the
fact that there were people you know who
potentially were promoting human
trafficking and using their wealth and
status to get get terrible things so we
were talking just a moment ago about
there there's this you know this list of
names and one of them's redacted we
think it's probably a name with 15
characters including a space giving a
total of 16 characters and somehow this
name got rejected I I'm loving all of
these all the speculation some people
are saying like Harvey Weinstein fits
sure but of all the names to be redacted
his would be the last cuz he's he's
locked up or I don't know is he's still
in jail he's still in jail and uh but
someone just super chatted Steven colar
and I'm just like okay well I really do
appreciate the hatred we have for the
corporate press I I'm I don't think
Steven coar has the National Security
level to keep that reduction uh it's a
lot of clout for Steven coar a lot of
clout for Sten considering like
billionaires and Millionaires and even
prince Andrew couldn't keep their names
out of it that's why I'm assuming
National security but uh good guesses
but it's all highly speculative I mean
we we got no idea I really the best way
to do it would be if you had you know
somehow compiled a list of people who
have been known to have flown on the
airplane and then you go through and you
count the characters because otherwise
like I could just shout out names for
the rest of forever and probably NE
wouldn't necessarily get close it has to
come from a list of people that were
already known or room which to have ties
to Epstein uh and I don't know
necessarily that Stephen colar was
there's a lot of names that fit and it's
kind of crazy because the chat's
lighting up and they're saying a bunch
of names and I'm like these names all
fit I just wonder at the end of all
these document drops at the end of it
we're just going to come out and be like
what is what at the end what is this
everybody's just going to be speculating
it's just anything's ever going to come
out out all this the way how they're
just dropping this like nothing changes
I I I don't think so I I don't I do not
believe that we're in a period where we
can say nothing changes because
everything has changed for the first
time in US history the former
president's been indicted
they're it's not just an indictment I
mean they're coming after ways they're
trying to keep them off the keeping them
off the ballot isn't is is is a de it's
it's soft War it is shutting down the
election the side that's doing that to
him is the side that's on the list so
they're going to prevent anything from
changing because they're not the ones
that they're people are if now Trump's
name was on the list then yeah sure no
but but this is the point they've never
been threatened before and now these
people on the list are doing things that
have never been done it's changed
something happened in this country that
has put these people in fear for their
for their lives social media and the
generation making up or or yes perhaps
that's what leads to a Donald Trump
election in 2016 they never thought
possible yeah and I do believe there's a
strong possibility that should Donald
Trump get elected yeah the names that
get released in this go to jail I do
believe that's possible I'm not saying
it's probable I'm not saying it's a
guarantee I'm saying I would not be
surprised look there's that clip going
viral right now where Donald Trump was
asked about Bill Clinton and he goes
nice guy but he's got a lot of stuff
coming up with that Epstein you know and
everyone's like what did Trump know
about this so what happens if Donald
Trump look Donald Trump says I your
retribution this guy's pissed there's a
possibility maybe it's 0.1% I don't know
he gets elected and the first thing he
does is he says I want to know everybody
who worked with Epstein and we're going
to lock them all up well he has to get
the FBI guys to do it well I think part
of it is that would be one of the only
ways to restore public trust I think
that if an average America I mean with
everything that happened with Hunter
Biden this year and him his plea deals
and this this very obvious two-tier
justice system I think if Trump were
elected actually seeing someone who is
on EP a known associate who partook in
all of this stuff being sent to prison
is actually the only way to get the
American people to think maybe there is
a reason to trust people we have a good
answer we have a good answer uh someone
said this is um Barrett 1313 it's Alan
dtz and the reason why his name was
redacted is because je fre uh uh
recanted her accusations against him La
in 2022 M so that could e but you know
what I got to push back on that his name
is all over these documents all over
them with accusations of raping children
so that being the case I don't think
this one time they redact his name does
William Burns fit he's a no no okay he
was CIA yeah he's CIA right now yeah but
he's like theoretically someone who flew
on one of Epstein's oh interesting so no
that's too short it's too short but look
no even if I'm learning something
amazing there are a lot of people in
government who have 15 character names
cuz people are posting all this stuff
I'm like oh that's actually a really
good point like there's too many of them
I don't know which one you pick talking
about The Hunt of Biden did you see the
reports from the Democrats from the
Democrat oversight they released a
report talk about like Donald Trump uh
obtained like $7.8 million from foreign
governments because they all stood in
his hotels when he was president so
they're trying to say that was form a
collusion that what the Republicans are
doing an attack and Hunter Biden Donald
Trump did as president and nobody's
really talking about it except for like
if you watch in the
MSNBC but they're trying to really make
it this as now the biggest deal ever it
was um Jamie Rasin he's doing this it
started today but because the everything
with the EP and everybody is really into
this I wouldn't be surprised if they're
they're going to try to turn the tables
and use that report against Trump as
another way they trying to throw
everything to make it stick at him and
they were already doing that when he was
in office though they tried to argue
repeatedly that he was making money off
yeah but no but they now releas 150 page
someone someone said ask grock this is
Joshua Park ask grock for powerful
people with 15 letter names so I went to
grock and I said give me a list of
politicians who have 15 characters
between their first and last name ladies
and gentlemen this list is damning okay
you ready is this American or foreign
Alexander Hamilton Benjamin Franklin
Thomas Jefferson James Madison George
Washington John Adams wait wait hold on
none of these none of these people have
15 characters in their names know oh so
grock is covering up for Epstein I knew
it I I knew this was corrupt I straight
to the top straight to the top free
speech my ass over
there that's crazy it's becoming a
foreign concept nowadays I mean I think
part of like first off I feel like this
is the new version of Wordle and I'm
really expecting it to like vibrant be
like you got some of the letters right
one of these them if uh like they should
do a crossword puzzle in the New York
Times and actually include this in there
who is the I'm sure Bill Clinton said
don't I wouldn't be surprised Bill
Clinton has already marched and it been
like do not dare don't you there uh that
would be so funny wasn't wasn't there a
case where like they he wanted delegates
to stay at Mara Lago and and host an
event there and they made him not do it
uh Trump during it when he was in office
what was that for do you remember that I
don't know deals I mean there was also a
report I saw a long time ago that Joe
Biden had personally hosted like
diplomats and his home in Delaware but
then I had a really hard time tracking
that down I think that there are
probably reasons people ask for things
like that but you know it's very easy to
be like no Mr President that is a
violation whatever and he's like okay
they can't see my golf course I mean
like there were all kinds of things like
there was a reason that Trump put his
sons in charge of the business and left
off you know what I mean like I think
you did as much as you could to mitigate
potentially having conflict in that case
the thing about Hunter Biden is that the
more that comes out about his case the
more obvious is through his emails and
everything that he was specifically
saying I am the pre the son of an
influential American politician and give
me my money if if if you do what if you
if I get benefits you get benefits
and there's no evidence that in the
Trump organization has that yeah but
that's what they're try to do they're
try to say like he didn't recuse himself
which he actually did I remember that
press conference right before during his
um the transition and they're trying to
say like he didn't recuse himself his
name was still under the Trump
organization they were trying to still I
mean his name was still literally Trump
and to a certain extent yes of course
that name gained even more prominence
than it already had but on the other
hand you know as far as I know and I'm
not an expert on his business dealings
it's not like he was like I am president
Trump now Eric go tell everyone in
Ireland that I'll open a golf course
there and because I'm the president like
it it wasn't that way that's very
different they act like like the Trump
Hotel was created in 2015 it's not like
he was doing this you know for decades
beforehand yeah it's very very strange
but you know I obviously think it's
important to hold politicians their
families accountable I mean this is
what's interesting about um all of the
legislation that that's getting posted
in Congress right now saying we should
be really wary of the stock trades being
made by politicians sorry grock is so
stupid I I asked it for a list of
politicians with 15 characters in their
names and it gave me a list of just
first it gave me like James so it gave
you the first 15 people so then I said
give me a list of politians alive today
and it gave me a list of random
politicians and I said none of those I
wrote none of those people have 15
letters in their names and it goes oh
I'm sorry that list didn't uh actually
adhere to what you had asked and then it
went I I I said so make a list with 15
uh letters and uh let me me see if I can
pull back up I close it 15 characters
right cuz obviously space in it and and
then it said apples bananas cherries
dates elderberries figs grapes honeydew
Iceberg I just put it I'm like okay this
idiot those are like code names it's on
regular mode it's not on fun mode should
we ask uh what's the other one Gemini
chat GPT CH GPT thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next
time